[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den letzten 14 tagen ging es
eigentlich nur noch um die frage steht
bei peter feldmann ergebnisse sechs oder
sieben vorne jetzt ist es die 7 es ist
also alles so gekommen wie nach dem
ersten wahlgang zu erwarten war
wie wird mal drei faktoren grob anführen
für den wahlsieg frankfurt hat
eigentlich seit dem krieg eine
strukturelle linke mehrheit in der
bevölkerung mal mehr mal weniger
acht der elf oberbürgermeister seit dem
krieg in frankfurt wurden von der spd
gestellt das hat sich auch jetzt wieder
gezeigt dass zweiter die frankfurter cdu
ist in keiner guten verfassung schon
seit längerem nicht das haben die leute
gemerkt wenn man so deutliches ergebnis
hat wird man nicht behaupten können dass
alles richtig gemacht wurde und dass
alles optimal gelaufen ist
das wäre da würde man sich selber etwas
vormachen wir werden uns das in ruhe
anschauen müssen
[Musik]
die kandidatin bernadette weyland eine
sympathische frau hat einen
schrecklichen wahlkampf geführt
es ist nicht es ist ihr nicht gelungen
zu sagen wofür sie stehen würde als
oberbürgermeisterin
ich mich einbringen
und das dritte ist peter feldmann hat
ganz offenbar in seiner ersten amtszeit
ist verstanden themen aufzugreifen die
den leuten auf den nägeln brennen
vor allem das thema wohnungsbau aber
auch öffentlicher nahverkehr und das
zusammengenommen hat heute zu dem
ergebnis geführt dass ich glaube dass
die menschen die ihre interessen
wahrgenommen haben den letzten jahren
die mieterin mieter der nassauischen
heimstätte diejenigen die bei der apg
für mit preisstopp gekämpft haben die
schüler die für ihre fahrpreise sich
eingesetzt haben diejenigen die als
jugendliche dafür eingestanden sind dass
in schulen saniert werden das sind viele
die jetzt diesmal mich unterstützt haben
das erklärt dieses wahlergebnis
frankfurts probleme hätten andere städte
sehr sehr gern frankfurt ist eine
wachsende stadt alle kurven zeigen nach
oben bevölkerung arbeitsplätze
wirtschaftskraft selbst die eintracht
hat einen tabellenplatz von dem sie
jahrelang nur träumen könnte aber genau
darauf muss die politik die
kommunalpolitik jetzt eine antwort
finden also werden für diese wachsende
stadt noch ihre wohngebiete ausgewiesen
und es wird auch darum gehen wie kann
frankfurt sozusagen seinen seinen rang
als wirtschaftsmotor metropole behaupten
in einer konkurrenz die auch in
deutschland und europa stärker und
härter wird nochmal kurz anstoßen und
bisschen feiern wird schon sein aber
sie wissen ich bin jemand der sich da
nicht zu oft hat er betrinkt sondern ich
will morgen arbeitsfähig sein
ich freue mich auf die arbeit zu müssen
da eine andere vermutete mich erhole
mich bei der arbeit macht spaß